das ist halt die verteilte Grünen die ja
sollte das andere sein die für mich als
verbotspartei einfach sieht also am
liebsten möchten Sie dass wir kein Auto
mehr fahren das kann man hier in der
Stadt gerne wollen das kann man machen
ich komme aus der Fläche aus dem schönen
Landkreis wie du dann weg und Lüneburg
da geht's eben nicht der zweite Punkt
ist ich soll kein Fleisch mehr essen das
ist ja so immer am besten ähm und am
besten auch die Jagd sollte man
eigentlich verbieten bzw die Waffen dann
auch Zentrallagern und das sind alles so
Punkte das finde ich halt einfach schade
und da ziehe ich natürlich nicht mit ich
sage diesen Veggie day den wir ja mal
hatten jeder Politiker der also ein
Veggie der fordert für den da freue ich
mich auf ein schönes Stück Fleisch dass
ich auf den Grill lege
provozierend mal gesagt und ich finde
einfach es geht einfach